Android allows devices to run several
applications simultaneously switch
between them and at the same time notify
you when something new occurs in one of
them let's see an example of this on the
world's first Android phone the t-mobile
g1 when browsing interesting photos a
friend pings me on yahoo messenger a
notification appears on the status bar I
can click right on it to switch to the I
M and chat with my friend letting him
know that I've almost found the perfect
photo to switch between any of the
applications that are running on Android
simply long press the device's home
button you can have several applications
running simultaneously in the background
I'm currently using a few apps myself I
am the browser settings contacts and
music let's return to the browser say I
found some interesting pictures using
long press I can easily share the pics
with my friend on the menu click go to
URL to see the current location then
simply long press the URL you'd like to
copy and select copy then switch back to
I M by long pressing the home button
and paste the copied URL right into the
IM conversation
the seamless integration between your
apps on Android makes multitasking
effortless